House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022. Speaking to Deadline after
the Emmy ceremony, HBO president Casey Bloys
also confirmed that work on the show continues
with casting roles currently undergoing.
House of the Dragon will begin filming at
the beginning of 2021 and will air sometime
in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
It is the main reason Martin did not yet finish
the Winds of Winter book as he postponed writing
Winds of Winter to write Fire And Blood because
they knew this would be a material for a Game
of Thrones
successor show.
House of the Dragon will start with a build-up
towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself. Later
seasons, however, will be based on George
RR Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood
volume 2 book that will continue with Queen
Rhaenyra's son King Aegon lll reign and will
include Blackfyre rebellion and go all the
way to the end of the Targaryen dynasty, to
Robert’s Rebellion, including the rebellion
itself.
“If you’d like to know a bit more of what
the show will be about… well, I can’t
actually spill those beans,” Martin teased
in his blog, “but you might want to pick
up a copy of two anthologies I did with Gardner
Dozois, Dangerous Women, and Rogues and then
move on to Archmaester Gyldayn’s history,
Fire & Blood.”
Dangerous Women includes what press materials
describe as a “35,000-word novella” by
Martin called “The Princess and the Queen,
or, the Blacks and the Greens,” which is
“about the Dance of the Dragons, the vast
civil war that tore Westeros apart nearly
two centuries before the events of A Game
of Thrones.”
The Greens were the faction during the Dance
of the Dragons that supported the claim of
Aegon ll Targaryen, their rivals being the
Blacks, who supported the claim of Rhaenyra
Targaryen. Both were named for the color of
their clothes worn during one tourney.
Rogues, meanwhile, includes Martin’s story
“The Rogue Prince, or, a King’s Brother,”
which chronicles “the early life, adventures,
misdeeds, and marriages of Prince Daemon Targaryen,”
considered “one of the biggest rogues in
the entire history of Ice and Fire.”
Finally, the novel Fire & Blood, released
in November 2018, is the first novel of a
two-part history of the Targaryens in Westeros.
“Centuries before the events of A Game of
Thrones, House Targaryen — the only family
of dragonlords to survive the Doom of Valyria
— took up residence on Dragonstone,” according
to the book’s description on the author’s
site. “Fire & Blood begins their tale with
the legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator
of the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount
the generations of Targaryens who fought to
hold that iconic seat, all the way up to the
civil war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In addition to this, few casting calls have
been known, I’m speaking of that of Daemon
Targaryen, the Rogue Prince, further confirming
that the House of the Dragon will be about
Dance of the Dragons, the Targaryen civil
war.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
I get many questions from fans asking if they
need to even watch the show when they just
finished Fire And Blood book.
The answer is a huge yes.
Not only will there be differences between
the books and the show like it was with Game
of Thrones, but after reading Fire And Blood
book, you still don't know how most of the
events really played out.
Some would think that you could just read
the book Fire & Blood to know what will happen
in the show based on that very same book but
that's far from truth. Why?
Because Fire And Blood is not a non-conventional
novel, it is imaginary history book, and according
to George RR Martin himself, not very accurate
at that.
Because while Fire And blood book was written
by George RR Martin, it wasn't written from
him as facts, but rather through the perspective
of the Citadel's Archmaester Gyldayn who gathered
all the info and as many different sources
as he could and used it to write a book about
the Targaryen history. Some info is fake,
some info is true, some info is semi-true.
No one will know for a fact what was happening
in the real history until the House of the
Dragon airs in 2022.
The show unlike the book will contain truth,
it will depict what actually happened, not
the changed history, fake or semi-true, not
what might or might not have happened.
Fire & Blood is a complete history of House
Targaryen written by George R. R. Martin from
a perspective of Archmaester Gyldayn who wrote
it many decades after the events took place.
Sure, most of the main events such as battles
and deaths probably did happen, but as Gyldayn
says it in the books, the full truth about
what happened behind close doors, in the privacy
of stairwells, council rooms, and
bedchambers he does not fully know and he
turns to many different sources which usually
differ from one another.
He looks into the course of chronicles laid
down by Grand Maester Runciter and his successors
and many court documents as well.
Gyldayn looks into accounts written decades
later by the children and grandchildren of
those caught up in the events of these times.
Whilst there are undoubtedly of use, so much
time has passed between the event and the
recording that many confusions and contradictions
have inevitably crept in.
Unfortunately, this is also true for Gyldayn's
two accounts by firsthand observers that have
come down to him.
Septon Eustace who served in the royal sept
in the Red Keep during much of this time and
spent much time as a confidant and confessor
to King Viserys and his queens. His account
is biased, favoring Aegon II over Rhaenyra.
Second account is based upon the verbal account
of the court fool Mushroom who was present
at court for all of them; for King Viserys,
Princess and Queen Rhaenyra and both King
Aegons, the Second and the Third.
During his reign, King Baelor I Targaryen
had Mushroom's book burned on account of its
scandalous content.
There are several main sources for historical
information on the Dance of the Dragons, which
are frequently at odds with each other.
Gyldayn also uses source written by Grand
Maester Orwyle, who had served King Aegon
II Targaryenon his council and was arrested
by the forces of Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen
when she took the city. Orwyle wrote his account
while locked away in the black cells. Uncertain
about whether or not he would survive the
war, he attempted to paint himself in the
best light possible.
Grand Maester Munkun's The Dance of the Dragons,
A True Telling was based on Orwyle's account.
Using all these sources which often differ
from each other, archmaester Gyldayn wrote
his work, Fire And Blood, his work about the
history of House Targaryen.
This format brings up Martin's major thematic
point about the uncertainty of memory, and
history being written by the winners. Neither
side truly won the war, and the decades after
the war, both sides wrote their own biased
history books trying to put their actions
in a better light. Histories written by the
Greens depict Aegon II in good light and Rhaenyra
in bad.
On the other hand, histories written by the
Blacks do otherwise.
We will know exactly what happened in this
time period when the show comes out, and that's
why you cannot just read Fire And Blood book
and think you would know what actually happen
or what will happen on the show. Books are
written by Archmaester decades and decades
after the events happened, using many sources
that in most cases are very different from
each other and most of them are biased as
well.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens fought
Targaryens, bothers fought brothers, dragons
fought dragons. By the time it was over, thousands
were dead. The conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only House
Targaryen, but large parts of Westeros as
well. In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
The show won't jump straight into the fighting,
it will start with a few episodes of the prelude
to the Targaryen civil war, with King Viserys
l likely dying after a few episodes, which
is just enough to introduce us with all the
characters and which side they support as
the future heir, as well as to set up all
the animosity at the court.
King Viserys I Targaryen had three children
by his first queen, Aemma Arryn, but only
one, Princess Rhaenyra, survived to adulthood.
Lacking a son to succeed him, Viserys began
to train Rhaenyra to be his heir, named her
his heir and Rhaenyra soon acquired a support
of hundreds of lords and landed knights.
The king remarried in 106 AC, this time to
Alicent Hightower, and had four more children:
Aegon, Helaena, Aemond, and Daeron.
In 111 AC, a great tourney was held at King's
Landing on the fifth anniversary of Viserys's
marriage to Alicent. During the opening feast,
Queen Alicent wore a green gown, while Princess
Rhaenyra dressed in the red and black of House
Targaryen. The note was taken, and soon all
of Rhaenyra's supporters started wearing black
clothing, while all of Alicent's followers
started wearing green. Over the years, the
popular names applied to both factions were
inspired by the colors they wore: Rhaenyra's
supporters were called "the Blacks", and Aegon
II's supporters were called "the Greens".
Viserys I strengthened Rhaenyra's place in
the succession by marrying her in 114 AC to
Ser Laenor Velaryon - who himself had Targaryen
blood through his mother, Princess Rhaenys.
Rhaenyra gave birth to three sons—Jacaerys,
Lucerys, and Joffrey Velaryon—during her
marriage, although there were rumors that
the father of these princes was not Laenor,
but Ser Harwin Strong. After Laenor was murdered
in Spicetown in 120 AC, Rhaenyra married her
uncle, infamous Rogue Prince, Prince Daemon
Targaryen, younger brother to Viserys I. Her
sons by him were Aegon the Younger—called
so to distinguish him from his uncle, Alicent's
Aegon, who on occasion was called Aegon the
Elder—and Viserys.
The relationship between Rhaenyra and Alicent
declined early in Alicent's marriage to Viserys,
since both ladies had been trying to be the
realm's first lady, and there could only be
one. Alicent's father, Ser Otto Hightower,
had also disliked Rhaenyra's second husband,
Prince Daemon, since the beginning of Viserys's
reign.
The war began when King Viserys I died. His
designated heir for many years had been his
only surviving child by his first wife, his
daughter Rhaenyra. Since Viserys I later remarried,
however, and had several younger children
by his second wife, Alicent Hightower, the
eldest of which was Rhaenyra's half-brother
Aegon II. The Seven Kingdoms had never had
a Ruling Queen before, and many were troubled
by the thought of Rhaenyra succeeding to the
throne. By the inheritance laws of the Andals,
a younger brother succeeds ahead of an elder
daughter, but the Targaryens had never formalized
royal inheritance laws for their new realm
after the War of Conquest 130 years before.
Viserys I, however, had extracted oaths of
fealty from the major lords of the realm that
Rhaenyra would succeed him.
The same day that Viserys I died, Aegon II's
followers, the Greens, staged a coup, and
he was soon crowned in King's Landing. Rhaenyra,
as the Princess of Dragonstone, had her powerbase
on Dragonstone island, where she responded
by being crowned queen and declaring Aegon
a traitor.
Aegon II's main supporters were his mother
Alicent's family, the powerful House Hightower
that rules Oldtown as well as the Lannisters.
Rhaenyra's main supporters were her first
husband's family, House Velaryon, as well
as her mother's family, House Arryn and her
uncle and future husband, the most dangerous
man in the Seven Kingdoms and the most experienced
commander, Daemon Targaryen.
The Blacks were mostly in the northeastern
half of Westeros, while the Greens were mostly
in the southwestern half. Dorne was not yet
part of the realm and remained neutral during
the war. The Blacks included the Arryns, the
Starks, and the Tullys (along with most if
not all of the Riverlords, even the Freys).
The Starks felt bound by honor to remain true
to the fealty oaths they had made to Rhaenyra
when her father was still alive. Major Greens
included the Hightowers and Lannisters. Rhaenyra
had thought the Baratheons would support her,
but in what she saw as a major betrayal they
sided with Aegon II. The Greens faced their
own betrayal, however: they had assumed that
all of the Reach would side with the Greens,
but instead the northern half of the Reach
sided with the Blacks. Even some of the Hightowers'
own direct vassals in the south sided with
the Blacks. The Tyrells remained officially
neutral throughout the war.
The Greens had thought that the Greyjoys would
join them - not realizing that the great wealth
they controlled ironically made them a more
enticing target. Seeing little profit in sailing
all the way to the eastern side of Westeros
to raid the modest lands of the Vale or Dragonstone,
the Greyjoys nominally sided with the Blacks
in order to raid the Lannister-Hightower lands
along the eastern coast.
Despite the Greens controlling the wealthier
lands of Westeros, the Blacks had the advantage
of control of the seas. The Greens only had
the Redwyne Fleet to rely on for naval power,
while - through House Velaryon - Rhaenyra's
forces controlled most of the Royal Fleet.
After the Greyjoys sided with the Blacks,
however, the Iron Fleet tied up the Redwynes
in their raids on the west coast, giving the
Blacks free run of the eastern coast. The
Greens attempted to counter this by allying
with the Kingdom of the Three Daughters (an
alliance of Lys, Myr, and Tyrosh), whose fleet
assaulted Rhaenyra's fleets in the massive
Battle of the Gullet. A third of the Velaryon
fleet was lost, but two-thirds of the Three
Daughters fleet was destroyed, and the survivors
withdrew from the rest of the war. Overall,
this meant that despite the Greens' numerical
superiority, they had to slowly struggle to
march their armies over land to attack the
Blacks, instead of being able to quickly move
their larger armies by sea.
After Rhaenyra was crowned Queen by Daemon
at Dragonstone and declared her half brother
traitor, King Aegon II declared Rhaenyra and
Daemon traitors as well. After being persuaded
by his mother, Alicent and sister, Helaena,
Aegon dispatched Grand Maester Orwyle to Dragonstone
with a retinue under a peace banner, offering
Rhaenyra generous terms, but was refused.
Rhaenyra's sons departed on their dragons
to seek allies and make pacts on her mother's
behalf. Her eldest son, Jacaerys went visiting
the Arryns of the Eyrie, the Manderlys of
White Harbor, and the Starks of Winterfell.
Rhaenyra's second son, Lucerys, traveled to
Baratheons at Storm's End.
Prince Daemon led the blacks' attack on Harrenhal,
which was conquered without bloodshed-The
castellan, Ser Simon Strong, yielded when
he saw Daemon's dragon Caraxes. This conquest
led to victories of the blacks at the Burning
Mill and Stone Hedge and allowed the river
lords to gather at Harrenhal.
In the meantime, Jacaerys gained Lady Arryn
and the Lords Manderly, Borrell and Sunderland,
and Cregan Starkto Rhaenyra's cause, with
Lord Stark allying through the Pact of Ice
and Fire.
Lucerys flew to Storm's End, arriving before
a gathering storm. He found Prince Aemond
and his dragon Vhagar already present. Aemond
tried to get Lucerys into a fight, insulting
him, calling him a Strong bastard, but Lucerys,
who sworn to his mother not to fight, refused
him. He delivered his message to Lord Borros
Baratheon, but was refused and told to leave.
Borros prevented Aemond from attacking his
cousin in the castle, but did allow for the
prince to follow him. Mounted on his dragon,
Aemond caught up with Lucerys during a raging
storm. The fight between the two dragons did
not last long. Vhagar, being five times bigger,
had the advantage, and Arrax fell broken.
His head and neck washed ashore three days
later, along with the corpse of Lucerys.
Rhaenyra collapsed when learning of Lucerys's
death. Prince Daemon, at Harrenhal, sent a
raven to his wife, promising that her son's
death would be avenged.
Using one of his friends from King's Landing,
Daemon enlisted the help of a former serjeant
in the City Watch, known now only as Blood,
and a rat-catcher from the Red Keep, known
now only as Cheese. The two sneaked into the
Red Keep, using secret tunnels and hidden
doors, which brought them into the Tower of
the Hand. There, Queen Alicent was bound and
gagged, and her bed maid strangled. When Queen
Helaena and her three children appeared, Blood
and Cheese barred the doors and told Helaena
to choose which of her sons would die. Helaena
reluctantly chose Maelor, but Blood did the
opposite and killed Prince Jaehaerys instead.
The two fled with the prince's head.
The war was a stalemate, with many unexpected
victories as well as unexpected losses for
both sides, with no clear victor emerging.
Even King's Landing itself was attacked, though
there was no siege - Rhaenyra's new husband
Daemon (her own uncle) had reorganized and
essentially created the City Watch as it would
later be known, and they remained loyal to
him. After the Greens foolishly left the capital
city lightly defended to attack Rhaenyra's
armies gathering at Harrenhal, her forces
on Dragonstone moved against King's Landing,
and the Gold Cloaks threw the gates open at
their arrival.
The war eventually degenerated into near-anarchy
as a string of betrayals happened in rapid
succession on both sides. Rival kings started
popping up in different parts of the realm
- ranging from the Greyjoys behaving functionally
independent to Dragonriders deciding that
they would make better kings than Rhaenyra
or Aegon II, to even petty street thugs carving
out their own fiefdoms in King's Landing and
declaring themselves "king" of half the city.
There is many interesting and legendary side
characters as well.
We have a combination of Varys and Littlefinger
in Larys Strong being the one in the shadows
orchestrating many events and making kings
rise and fall.
We also have Melisandre is Alys Rivers, Aemond
Targaryen's mistress and perhaps that's even
Melisandre herself in her younger days. Alys
sees visions in the flames and has some great
powers.
Racallio Ryndoon, pirate-king, is another
legendary side character in this story. If
even half the stories about him are true,
he is probably one of the most insane and
most fascinating characters I've ever read.
It's a Targaryen civil war so of course Targaryens
and their dragons play the main role in the
series, but the Starks, Lannisters, Arryns,
Tullys and Hightowers are very important as
well.
One of the most exciting 1 on 1 fights is
definitely legendary Daemon Targaryen against
Aemond one-eye that happened above the Gods
Eye and resulted with both men and both their
dragons dying, although Daemon did win a fight
by piercing his Valyrian steel sword through
Aemond's eye socket but seconds later both
dragons hit a lake at a rapid speed.
Aemond's body was found but Daemon's was not.
Historians say Daemon died in this fight but
singers sing of his departure from Westeros
to live his days out in Essos.
I'm not going to talk about every single event,
but this all of the things I mentioned is
what essentially kick-started this Dance of
the Dragons, referring to Viserys's death,
animosity between the Greens and the Blacks
and especially the first fight where Rhaenyra
lost her son did it turn into a violent, long,
bloody tale full of revenge, violence, lust,
love and dragon-to-dragon aerial battles.
The civil war lasted two years and gutted
the Seven Kingdoms, with dragons burning out
vast swaths of the countryside, and entire
towns reduced to ashes. The devastation was
so great that it took a full generation to
recover.
At the start of the war, there were 20 living
dragons: 9 older and huge dragons, 8 younger
dragons still large enough to be ridden to
war, and 3 hatchlings too small to ride. By
the end of the war, all but three had died.
Another dragon was hatched near the end of
the war, bringing the total number of surviving
dragons to four. None of them would live for
long, and there were too few dragons left
to maintain a stable breeding population.
The last dragon, said to be a stunted creature,
died only 33 years after the war ended, later
in the reign of Rhaenery's son King Aegon
lll for which he became known as "Aegon the
Dragonbane"
Twenty major battles, even more, smaller battles,
and even more betrayals, turncloaks, and twists.
All of that this Game of Thrones prequel show,
House of the Dragon, brings in 2022.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and let me know what team you on
in the comment section down below. Team Blacks
supporting Rhaenyra or team Greens supporting
Aegon?